et aux états unis un record du nombre
d'arrestations de migrants illégaux à la
frontière avec le mexique au mois
d'octobre une hausse de plus de 50% par
rapport à l'année dernière à la même
époque
l'opposition dénonce la politique de
l'administration by donne les
explications de notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnin au mois
d'octobre 2021 les autorités américaines
ont annoncé avoir arrêté plus de cent
soixante quatre mille migrants le long
de la frontière entre les etats-unis et
le mexique c'est deux fois plus qu'au
même mois l'an dernier et c'est tout
simplement le nombre le plus élevé
jamais relevés pour un mois d'octobre
aux états unis alors du côté des
autorités on préfère regarder la
situation avec un prisme différent les
services frontaliers se félicite du fait
que le nombre d'arrestations est en
diminution en comparaison en tout cas
avec les niveaux records atteints cet
été octobre marque le troisième mois
consécutif de baisse du nombre
d'arrestations de migrants illégaux à la
frontière sud ouest avec une diminution
importante du nombre de familles et
d'enfants non accompagnés
la question de l'immigration est
évidemment un sujet épineux pour joe
biden l'année fiscale écoulée a montré
une hausse significative du nombre
d'arrivées illégales sur le territoire
américain en fait que les républicains
attribuent au changement de politique
mise en place par le président a
democrat le sujet
c'est notamment invité cette semaine
lors d'une audition au sénat du ministre
chargé de la sécurité nationale
les républicains ont multiplié les
critiques contre l'administration de joe
biden par exemple le sénateur du texas
tech cruz a interpellé le ministre sur
les conditions de détention des enfants
tant ce qu'il qualifie de cage un terme
récusé par le ministre mais tel cruz a
de nouveau présenté des images en
provenance de son état le texas lui qui
avait déjà publié au mois de mars
dernier une vidéo sur ces réseaux
sociaux où on pouvait voir des dizaines
voire des centaines de personnes
agglutinées dans des espaces très
réduits dans un hangar le long de la
frontière sud des états unis alors le
reproche principal qui est fait par les
républicains contre l'administration de
joe biden c'est que ni la vice
présidente ni le président américain ne
semble avoir pris la mesure sont à eux
de la réelle situation le long de la
frontière sud du pays le ministre
interrogé lors de cette audition au
sénat a d'ailleurs confirmé que ni
kamala harris ni joe biden ne s'était
rendu en personne pour visiter ces
centres de détention des migrants
arrêtés par la police aux frontières il
faut dire que c'est un sujet très
compliqué pour joe biden dans un
contexte de recul de sa cote de
popularité un sondage au mois d'octobre
dernier a indiqué que seul un américain
sur trois approuvent est la façon
qu'avait le président démocrate de gérer
le dossier des migrations